Today, we're going to learn
how to make the most basic vitality pills.
The procedures are simple,
so I'm going to make it quick.
I hope you can keep up with me.
-Yes.
STEPS TO MAKE VITALITY PILLS
INSTRUCTOR: PAN SHENGCONG
Steps to make vitality pills.
First, get a Yangcheng pot ready.
Next,
take gold sand,
tortoiseshell, and dragon bone.
Cut up, grind, and put it in.
Cut up some Acorus tatarinowii.
Cut up some Radix polygalae.
Scatter it in.
Add Powder Number 15
and 7 drops of lapis lazuli oil.
Flatten it, put it in the furnace,
and close it.
Tape it, seal up the furnace,
and start the fire.
Set the alarm to 5 p.m.
Are you all clear about the process?
Now let's see what you can do.
It's time for me to show them
what I've got.
First, refining pills is an art of fire.
The big cauldron of the Chen family
was designed for refining
large quantities of pills.
For a small quantity like this,
it's hard to control the time for heating.
Sun Rong behaves like she knows something.
She even brought the refining machine
from her family's factory?
Does that even count as her own effort?
What?
Someone is using a microwave oven
to do the refining.